[Music]
hello everyone i'm tim harford i'm a bbc
presenter financial times columnist
professional nerd and author of a brand
new book called how to make the world
that up with obligatory that i wave this
book around um
the how to make the world that up is a
book about
thinking clearly about the world by
thinking clearly about the numbers and
thinking clearly about yourself
um but i'm actually not here to talk
about how to make the world add up
instead i want to pull a story
out of that book and i want to tell i
want to tell you the story and
the story is is a tale of
fusty old victorians some of them have
bonnets and all of them have tight
fitting clothes with far too much starch
and you you might wonder for a moment
why i would tell you such a story but
it's also a tale of hospitals being
overwhelmed
of a deadly infectious disease
of
national catastrophe
bungling
arguments about whether anything could
be done or not and graphs lots and lots
and lots of graphs
and so i think i don't need to explain
why this old story might have a lesson
or two for us to learn today
and the story really begins in
the hospital at
schootari barracks in istanbul this is
on the
the east side the asian side of the
bosphorus and skitari barracks
when constructed in the early 1800s they
were the largest barracks anywhere in
the world
but by the mid-1850s
they were to become the largest hospital
anywhere in the world they had been
converted
to be an emergency military hospital
receiving casualties from the british
army which was fighting
elsewhere on the black sea
over in crimea in a particularly uh
pointless war
amid a century of pointless wars
and
our hero
a young woman called florence
nightingale first saw scootari barracks
from the ship as she sailed up the
bosphorus
and she commented that
to innocent eyes
these qatari barracks seemed magnificent
there now white marble their towers
but she later reflected
to our eyes
they were whited sepulchers
pest houses
because when nightingale arrived to take
charge of the nursing
at the hospitals several hospitals in
schootari
what she encountered was a humanitarian
catastrophe
that she wrote a note to a friend
a doctor back in england
oh you gentlemen of england can have
little idea
from reading the newspapers
of the horror and misery in a military
hospital of operating upon these dying
and exhausted men
that this is the kingdom of hell
no one can doubt
the british army was ill-equipped
to be fighting in crimea and the
hospital was particularly
ill suited
nightingale
begged the um the quartermasters of of
the british army to supply her with the
equipment that she needed but they
seemed to delight in
not giving her possible a woman in a
man's world not giving her what she
wanted so again she wrote back home to
complain of the situation
no mops no plates no wooden trays no
slippers no shoe brushes no blacking no
knives and forks no spoons no scissors
for cutting the men's hair which is
literally alive no basins no toweling no
chloride of lime
this wasn't just a complaint that she
didn't have the equipment she needed to
do her job um it was part of a campaign
florence nightingale was
remarkably effective
at
using the press
to gain what she wanted to arouse
public interest public sympathy public
anger about what was happening in the
hospitals in schootary and what was
happening
was appalling
so men would be
brought into the hospital that they
would
lie there shivering cold
they would die of their wounds or of
diseases they would be stitched up in
their own blankets and then carried out
to be
dumped in a mass grave
leaving space for the next man
to take their place
the british army was shredded
over the winter of
1855
by infectious diseases
many of which were in those hospitals
ten percent
of the entire
strength of the british army
died 10 of the men in the british army
died in that one month alone
january 1855
and throughout all of this nightingale
was trying to figure out what was
happening
how to deal with it how to raise the
money get the supplies that she needed
and above all how to prevent these men
from dying
by
the spring
april may
things have become significantly better
the death toll had dramatically fallen
the hospitals were in better order
um and nightingale in fact felt able to
travel over
to the crimean peninsula itself
and by this time
she was pretty much the only figure in
the entire waging of the crimean war
whose reputation was still intact the
politicians were in disgrace the
generals were in disgrace florence
nightingale was well on her way to
becoming a saint
and as she observed the troops around
the siege of sebastopol
they gave her three cheers she was so
moved by the spectacle
but then shortly afterwards returning to
the camp at balaclava in crimea
on the 13th of may
florence nightingale suddenly collapsed
and very soon
the rumors started to spread around the
camp
the florence nightingale was dying
now when i think about how we view
florence nightingale today
uh it's extraordinary she's a sort of
john lennon of nursing
marked by this the tragic early passing
that ripped her away from us uh
celebrated put on the
the covers of magazines the big issue
put florence nightingale on the cover of
the magazine of their magazine very
early on in the pandemic all hail
nightingale
the hand-washing queen we named our
emergency hospitals after her we put her
on the banknote she was the only woman
other than the queen
on english banknotes in the 20th century
my own mother
when she died in
1996 she took her last breath
in a florence nightingale hospice
she's absolutely everywhere
the curious thing about this
is that she really isn't the john lennon
of nursing
she didn't die
that day at balaclava
she recovered at least partially
and
instead of passing away at the age of 35
she went on to live to the age of 90.
and it's really what she did
in those
decades and decades of life that were
given to her when people thought she was
dying what she did then
that is what really fascinates me and
that's what i want to talk about
now you see this is really
a story about an argument over public
health
and the weapons that were used to fight
in that argument and what those weapons
can teach us about today
what florence nightingale did almost
immediately on returning from crimea was
to speak to the queen queen victoria i
mean nightingale was the most famous
woman in the british arm uh british
empire other than victoria herself
and she persuaded victoria to
set up a royal commission
um to investigate
what it was
that had happened in those crimean
hospitals and what lessons more
generally could be learned
and there was a particular
event that has made a huge impression on
nightingale
in march of 1855 just after this utterly
catastrophic winter
a commission had come
from
the uk
with the doctor john sutherland and
others
at the request of nightingale and they'd
inspected the hospitals and tried to
figure out um how to improve conditions
there
and they've done some pretty basic
things for example they discovered that
there was a a dead horse
in the main water supply to one of the
hospitals
they discovered that latrines
were um were leaking into the water
supply so effectively uh cholera from
these soldiers was just draining from
the sewage directly back into the
drinking water and they've done other
things like uh whitewash the walls with
antiseptic um
lime paint they'd clear away the the
dead dogs and nightingale was all for
this um she commented in another of her
letters the sanitary commission is
really doing something and has set to
work burying dead dogs and white washing
walls two prolific causes of fever
now
after the sanitary commission had done
its work
the conditions in the hospitals were
vastly more pleasant but also the death
rate was vastly lower and nightingale
observed this and she thought there was
no coincidence to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas